foreign
Charles is in my hometown there in
Massachusetts Charles welcome to the
show how you doing
hi it's honest bq2 you as well how can
we help
um okay uh basically I've I've screwed
up my life I know that
um and I don't see any way out of it I
don't know how to even start or what
what way to go but my my student loans
are 150 000 and they're not coming down
and um my house payment my house
mortgage is 120 000 and so since my
house is less than my student loans when
you do a dead snowball do I pay off the
house first and then the loan but either
way it's it's going to be years before I
can even come close to paying off
anything and then how do you do
something like that I got kids at home
how do you do something like that and
not find yourself singing Cats in the
Cradle in a few years well Charles who
told you that your life is over
well it's it's like I can I can try I
don't see any way of paying this off you
know
um what's your income uh at least let's
put some facts on paper
uh okay uh I take home
um my household income is maybe 45 to 50
000 depending on if I can get overtime
and that's the most I've ever made in my
life okay
what do you do for that I don't do
um right now I'm a mechanic at a um
amusement park out here I was lucky that
they gave me that job what's your degree
in you said you have 150 in student
loans
yeah I have a degree in elementary
education and uh Masters in school
administration
I'm 48 my wife's uh 53 and she's not
able to work or drive or anything
does she have any disability income
yeah she has a disability but but she
gets um about a hundred dollars a month
in Social Security that's all she was
able to get but my other daughter who
lives with us is disabled and she gets
about eight hundred dollars a month so
that's what's saving us basically well
Charles you've called the right place we
like calls like this because we have
seen thousands of people in situations
like yours with six figures in debt get
completely debt free
so first of all your life is not over
you have not screwed up so bad that you
can't come back from this you absolutely
can we actually have a personality that
joined recently who paid over four
hundred thousand dollars in debt off
and we've seen that multiple times so I
just want to encourage you that you are
in the right spot and if you're willing
to fight for it you can get out of this
and also just with the student loans you
said that it's 150 and it's not going to
come down I believe it's going to come
down pretty quick you're you're educated
I think your income potential is pretty
high right now you're 45 and 50 and I
think we can really bump that up
um but yeah I think first just getting
out of the mindset that this is too
desperate of a situation to get out of
how does that feel to you do you feel
like you can do this
um I I think I can it's just that when I
look at the numbers it would be like
um if I even paid if I paid like 1300 in
my student loans even that would take 30
years if I pay 1200 which is what my
mortgage is that's 30 years and and so I
can pay 1500 on my mortgage and be done
in 15 years so I was planning on doing
that but then it's like you have to work
you know because they'll speed and all
that but if you do that it's like you
become a workaholic and then your kids
are like you know where were we you paid
off all your money gazelle intensity is
meant for a few years it's not meant for
decades at a time and so uh number one
we're gonna send you Financial Peace
University as well as every dollar
that's our Proven Plan nine lessons the
budget the full kit and caboodle go
through that but I would not pay off the
mortgage before the student loans you
can't bankrupt on the student loans you
can get rid of a mortgage by selling
your house one day you can't get rid of
Sallie Mae and so I'm attacking that
first save the house for baby step six
and let's send them from paycheck to
purpose because I think you need a
bigger shovel let's get that income up
so you can pay this off quicker